hello everyone and welcome to the long
awaited match from round four of the
Oslo Esports cup it's a Magnus Carlson
versus pragyananda they are both having
a pretty pretty good event but
pragananda is having an Immaculate event
uh he won uh all three of his matches
with um uh with perfect scores and uh is
here in the Oslo Esports cup you get
more money if you win games than you
actually draw and then win in tie breaks
uh after three matches pragananda has
already won I believe uh 20 to 22 000 uh
dollars or or somewhere around that
number so while that is very impressive
we are here at uh enjoy chess and this
is one match that we were looking
forward to very very much Magnus has the
white pieces uh and he opens with E4 uh
Prague opens uh with C5 or rather
counters E4 with C5 he goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 Knight to
C6 and now Bishop to B5 Magnus goes for
the uh news Medina of uh rosalimo attack
against Sicilian as he often does we
have G6 by Prague at Castles by Magnus
and now Bishop to G7 we have D3 and
Knight to F6 with Bishop captures on
these and c6d captures and C6 and now
Magnus goes Rook to E1 uh preparing to
advance the E5 Pawn you could Advance
the E5 Pawn right away but here Magnus
is still uh waiting with the idea so
here we have Castles by Prague and now
Pawn to H3 we have Queen to C7 and only
now Magnus pushes E5 so the position has
been reached before uh however only in a
handful of games and the E5 was never
played here so as of move 9 we have a
completely new game uh we have knighted
the D5 and not Knight B to D2 and now as
the bishop no longer controls the F4
Square uh Prague shifts his Knight over
to F4 uh Magnus plays Knight the E4
opens up an attack on the Knight here
and now Bishop captures an E5 so it's a
temporary Pawn sacrifice but well as
you'll see only a temporary one Knight
captures an E5 Queen characters on E5
and here Knight the C3 now challenging
the queen also the queen has to keep an
eye on the Knight on F4 so Queen back to
C7 Magnus picks up the knight uh Queen
captures on F4 and now we have Rook
captures on E7 uh Magnus wins back the
pawn but Prague says not so quick Bishop
captures an H3 and now it's in fact
Prague who is up a pawn but Magnus again
grabs the B7 Pawn will captures on B7
now if you're wondering what happens if
G captures an H3 well while you could
play this then comes Queen to G5 check
and you blunder The Rook on E7 so
instead we have Rook captures on B7 and
now uh Prague just goes back Bishop to
C8 you could play Bishop to F5 Bishop to
E6 but he has a very specific idea he
wants to limit the the movement of the
Rockstar Magnus goes Rook to E7 and now
Bishop to E6 so now if you're not
careful a move like Queen to f 6 could
be or queen to D6 could be a lot of a a
lot of trouble for you so Magnus goes
Queen to C1 you could also consider
Queen to F3 but Queen to C1 uh is a a
little bit um stronger for white as
you'll see Magnus has seven minutes on
the clock whereas Bravo has three and a
half minutes so uh that is going well
for Magnus and here uh for example if
Queen to D6 which of course is an idea
you don't want to play Queen G5 you
cannot defend the Rook because F6 and
then you just blunder The Rook again but
a rook to B7 and then after Bishop the
C8 challenging The Rook we're gonna play
Knight to e for this was Carlson's idea
and after Queen E5 we're gonna play Rook
to B3 now comes C4 of course The Rook is
attacked if you capture then you lose
the Knight so Rook the C3 and now after
something like captures captures it is a
white who will be putting pressure on on
Black's position so instead we have a
queen to H4 by prago and the now Rook
the C7 going after the Double C pawns
and here here well you could play
something like Bishop to D5 and it's
probably the uh something to do for
example captures captures and captures
uh probably uh doesn't like this so he
plays C4 a very active way to play D
captures on C4 Queen captures on C4 now
keeping an eye on the a C6 pawn and
queen to E3 and now uh you have to
decide now probably uh Queen Bishop to
F5 going after the C2 Pawn is uh better
in the long run but these are all rapid
games as I uh often remind you so Bishop
to D5 was played in now Magnus simply
captures it Knight captures on D5 Queen
captures and D5 and now Rook captures an
A7 grabbing that pawn and you can see
now that uh Magnus is up upon not only
that he has the past a pawn so here we
have Rook back to E8 attacking the queen
here Rook to E7 not allowing to give up
the E file and here we have a trade
captures captures and now Queen for
putting pressure on the B2 pawn and we
have C3 and queen to D2 now Magnus still
has six minutes on the clock whereas
progo has two minutes how do you defend
the pawn uh while you could play
something like Rook to B1 after uh Queen
to C2 attacking The Rook it's a very
annoying annoying position you have to
play very passive play the Queen back to
E1 and now I have to Rook the B8 how do
you defend the B2 Pawn if you push it
then you lose the A2 pawn and so on so
instead after Queen D2 Magnus plays
Queen to B7 defense his Pawn also puts
pressure on the C6 pawn and here we have
Rook the E8 by prago activating The Rook
uh you could try something like H5 and
say okay let's just go all out let white
do his thing on the queen side but it's
not all that impressive let's say H4 we
can even play Queen captures on c6h3 uh
okay you open up the king a little bit
but uh White really really doesn't care
here so instead after Queen to B7 we
have rooked the E8 uh praguna once the
trade Rooks and uh go into a queen and
Pawn end game Queen captures on C6 and
now Rook the E1 with check Magnus
captures we have Queen captures and now
King to H2 and queen captures on F2 so
this is the queen and pawn end game that
we are talking about uh where Magnus has
three
um uh connected pass pawns on the queen
side but uh it's Queen upon end game
that just might not be enough and you
have to play it very precisely and the
Magnus does play it very precisely Queen
to E8 with Chuck King G7 now Queen to E5
with check we have F6 and now Queen to
E7 with check
uh King to H6 uh King to G8 could be a
bit more resilient but Prague wants to
hide his King so he can start giving
checks if Magnus is not very careful uh
Queen to H4 followed by Queen day one
could result in a Perpetual for example
if Magnus loses control over D1 Square
so here we have B4 uh this is not
possible for the moment as Magnus does
control the E1 square and now comes
Queen to F4 if you capture on A2 then
recapture on F6 and then it's just of
course winning for white so after B4 we
have Queen to F for check now probably
uh hoping to get some sort of a
Perpetual here King to G1 now comes
Queen to C1 check King F2 Queen to D2
check and now Queen to E2 Magnus blocks
the check hopes the trade queens and now
Queen to F4 with check we have Queen to
F3 Queen back to D to check and King G3
so uh progo prevents Carlson's King from
going to the queen side and uh he asks
what do you do now yeah so first uh King
G7 now you uh I have a bit more options
because well for example if you have the
king and F3 and let's say queen F3 check
is played then Prague will be forced to
trade Queens this way he can uh well you
use a bit more space so A4 Magna starts
pushing the pass Pawn we have Queen to
G5 with check King F2 Queen back to D to
check Queen to E2 now Queen captures on
C3 Magnus could uh try something else
but he decides that giving up the pawn
is the best way to seize Advantage so
Queen E2 Queen captures on C3 and now
Queen to E7 with check and this is a
very good move by Magnus because it puts
prox King in complete passivity of
course King to H6 is no longer possible
because now Queen to E3 check we trade
queens and now of course the position is
just winning for y to the Past a pawn is
too fast so uh here we have King to G8
and now we have A5 uh starting to push
those past pawns we have Queen to D2
with check King to G3 now outcomes G5
and here Magnus has to be very very
careful if he pushes the pawn and
doesn't look what progo is doing just
Queen F4 checking H3 and queen H4 will
be Checkmate so Magnus first place Queen
captures on F6 this picks up a pawn
while defending against Checkmate and
now it's gonna be very hard for Prague
to defend this queen to E1 check we have
Queen to F2 now comes Queen captures and
B4 Magnus even gives up the B Pawn
because now he says the a pawn is
winning we have Queen to F5 defending
and attacking the pawn so Queen to E1
with check King to G4 and now we have
Queen to B4 with check again if you play
Queen T to check we just capture on G5
and
um okay here you could capture on G2 and
this is probably uh what what could have
happened but after Queen to E2 check
um yeah you you kinda can't capture this
you have to go back and then Magnus
would have to figure out a different way
to play this but Fargo played Queen to B
for check and this allows Magnus to just
uh continue pushing queen king captures
on G5 Queen to D2 with check with King
the H5 and now Queen to D6 cutting off
the king from going to H6 this would
help a lot in in trying to Checkmate the
black king but also keeping an eye on
the A6 Square so Magnus can't just
continue pushing the pawn and also you
are threatening Queen Tage to check the
King has to move and then you're gonna
pick up the G2 Pawn with the check so
Magnus blocks this with the G3 and it's
quite a tricky idea if Queen captures
then Queen G5 check just trades queens
and then Crossings Apon will be winning
so after G3 Prague plays Queen to C6 and
now we have Queen a king to G5
uh King to G7 and now Queen to E5 with
the Chair King F7 Queen to F4 with check
and now King to G7 now interestingly
both players are now below the one
minute Mark we have Queen to D4 check
came to G8 and now Queen the B6 Magnus
uh spent uh well quite a lot of time
since he only had a minute left on the
clock to calculate this queen to B6 idea
uh but it is an idea that definitely
works as you'll see Queen D5 track we
have King the F6 and now comes Queen to
F3 with Chuck uh kinta E7 and the now
comes Queen to A3 with check so this is
the idea that Magnus was calculating uh
now white is completely winning here but
you have to play a very very precise
move uh so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute best
move for white uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting This
brilliant idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to D6 that's the good stuff now you
could just move the king and you would
probably still be able to win but this
just forces a win and now uh capturing
this Pawn doesn't work uh because uh
products King is in a mating a net uh if
Queen captures an A5 we just play Queen
E6 check King G7 Queen F6 check King
Jade force and now Queen Death 8 will be
Checkmate so here uh after Queen to D6
probably played Queen to F3 uh but not
Magnus can finally continue pushing his
past Pawn we have Queen to F7 with check
King to d8 now comes Queen to A2 uh but
uh it doesn't help King to C7 Crossings
King finally reaches the queen side
Queen to F7 check King to B6 now comes
Queen to B3 check into A7 Queen to F7
check now King to A8 uh we have Queen to
F3 with check with King the B8 uh Queen
to be B3 and finally King the C8 we have
Queen to C4 checking the king attacking
the pawn so you have to be careful but
now King to B7 and after Queen to B3
check Queen to B6 now we can finally
start blocking check with our queen
queen F3 check King the A7 and now of
course you cannot uh deliver a check
because we're just gonna block with the
queen uh so Queen to A3 was played uh
but now we have King the A8 King to G7
again a check along the back rank
doesn't work because we just block with
our Queen and force the queen trade so
after King eight King to G7 was played
but now A7 and we are very close to the
end uh uh Queen to f8 uh Queen to fade
with check with King to B7 Queen to F3
with check Queen to C6 Queen to B3 with
check and here Magnus played King the C8
uh and it was in this position on move
76 that pragananda resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so once you deliver one more checklist
the queen to GH check King to C7 will be
played and then there are no more useful
checks because after Queen F7 we can
just block with our Queen and of course
the king and pawn end game is winning
for Magnus so a very nice game a very
very nicely fought by Prague but Magnus
was very resilient he was um uh well
accustomed to the line after that Bishop
captures an H3 idea uh very early on uh
in the game uh Magnus was very quick to
just follow up with we will capture some
B7 even though the position is
incredibly complicated but he knew what
was happening and probably had to waste
more time than Magnus did and in the end
the Magnus used that very well in this
queen and pawn end game uh so after King
C8 uh Prague resigned and the game one
of this uh well a very very anticipated
match goes to Magnus Carlsen uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it and that you were able in in sporting
that Queen to D6 idea it's not an easy
one to find especially since you have to
give up the the past Pawn that you've
been protecting for so long but that's
what it sometimes takes the uh to win a
queen opponent game and it is most
likely what Magnus was calculating here
when he spent a lot of time going for
this queen to B6 idea uh but yeah that
the game hope you guys uh enjoyed it
we'll see if uh probably can bounce back
like we said he won all three matches he
played so far will he be able to bounce
back against Magnus and maybe win the
fourth one uh we'll see what happens uh
sir I hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Andrew dabrowski Kirsten
lemon's gallupless course DK Benjamin
and Mark galassi for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the curvature of this uh well
uh very enjoyable cup uh checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and yes for
those of you who have been asking in the
comment section of the previous video uh
Meadow did definitely have some of the
fish so see you soon